the Joe Rogan experience you didn't have
to deal with that at Artie but what do
you think happens when someone is a
pundit and they're on a television show
and they're talking about something that
has these global implications do you
think they get talking points do you
think they're allowed to express their
own personal opinions or are they
informed that they're supposed to toe a
certain line
I think there's varying levels I think
that it would be naive to say okay these
people are paid to lie I think that the
majority of people working in corporate
media are lackeys for the Empire they
really truly believe that you know they
believe that America is the greatest
country in the world they believe that
were the world's policemen they actually
believe that these countries are evil
and they need to be taken out to
in-state kind of global hegemony I've
truly believed that they cater to the
line of American exceptionalism and
that's pretty sad but also pretty
dangerous because they're the perfect
mouthpieces for u.s. foreign policy I
mean they essentially are stenographers
for whatever the government is laying
out which is really disturbing because
the premise of journalism is to actually
challenge power and challenge the US
government especially when you are
working in America you're an American
citizen and there's all this destruction
going on from on behalf of your
government and you're not challenging
that especially when it's war claims
especially when you have [ __ ] like
John Bolton claiming you know all these
things are happening in these channels
and and bodies of water and people are
just like okay I mean goddamn you should
see when [ __ ] Mike Pompeo was talking
about how Hezbollah was in Venezuela and
these people will just just printed it
they're like well Hezbollah is in
Venezuela now it's like what are you
talking about you're literally just
printing what the Trump administration
is saying without even questioning these
claims mmm that's disturbing do you
think that the people that are talking
about it on TV are just saying it
because they really don't understand
what they're talking about and this just
seems to be a way to cover the subject
in sort of a way that is acceptable to
the network and acceptable to the party
and acceptable to this sort of idea
whether it's left or right with it
whatever ideology they're they're
participating in
yes and that there there is definitely
that as well where they know kind of the
line that they can't cross so even if
you individually believe you know you
think that climate change is an
existential threat you think that the
warned Yemen is a serious thing that you
should address I think that you
definitely get kind of knocked down in
the editorial meeting you know before
and you're just like okay no I can't do
that but what I can't do is just you
know talk about whatever that's it's so
weird the advertisers will agree with in
this day and age there's not like a
really respected independent source of
news right that you've got you some the
online stuff which is money some online
stuff is very good but some online stuff
is so entangled with insults and and and
[ __ ] and emotions and distorted
perceptions and ego that it's like it
sort of discredits whatever they're
trying to promote whatever whatever
ideas are trying to get across there's
no Walter Cronkite there's no there's no
one person who or no one organization
who you emphatically trust with their
perspective on the news everything is
either left or right everything is like
flavored by an ideology right sorry I
don't place that I go to that I know I
can get clear unbiased emotion free
objective analysis of any international
issue right it doesn't exist I don't
mean unless you can tell me if one do
you what do you give I mean I go to real
news I go to Democracy Now and the only
now super left-wing right
left-wing leaning but you think
left-leaning I mean I go to places that
are not this is the problem like with
capitalism and trying to have an
independent media is that you need
funding and and you need funding from
like donors and grassroots sources
because once you get funded by these
right-wing billionaires and corporations
and states and governments then it
becomes very ideologically driven and
then you're kind of just catering toward
what those interests want you to present
and I that's why the Empire files does
what it does it's we're basically based
on donations now because
Trump's sanctions on Venezuela shut down
the show a year ago so we did a big
donation drive and that's an open atrium
patreon we're on GoFundMe and just pay
pal but we're just trying to survive on
a very minimal budget because I don't
want to take you know I don't want to
like lobby to corporations or States or
or go that route because I don't want to
I don't want to answer to anyone other
than myself but then you just come with
a whole host of problems you're not
getting your message out there I mean
that's why it's incredible for you to
have me on but that's why the fake news
mantra resonated so much with the Trump
campaign because people are extremely
disillusioned with the corporate media
you know New York Times Washington Post
these so-called Beltway publications
that pretend to be like the arbitrator's
of a are objective reality they they are
the premier advocates of fake news when
it comes to US foreign policy you know
American exceptionalism and corporations
and like the corporate line they're
always the ones towing the things that
basically prop up the system and so I
think people you know became really
really just attracted to that whole fake
news mantra that Trump was saying
because people have an extreme distrust
in the corporate media because of the
Iraq war because of all these things
that have happened
[Applause]